if you're on Twitter or Instagram you
may have noticed more and more people
dabbling with socialism not that kind of
socialism drunken socialism bars and
restaurants selling bottles of expensive
or rare alcohol one ounce at a time at
cost so if you can't shell out over $800
for a bottle of 25 year old Macallan you
can still get a taste for around 37
bucks of course this isn't socialism at
all it's just shrewd capitalism because
sometimes giving away a little bit at
cost or even at a loss is good business
they come in for for this and then
they'll stay for a really great
old-fashioned John Mayer is owner of the
rogue gentleman bringing drunken
socialism to Richmond Virginia and yes
judging by his t-shirt democratic
socialism as well more on that later we
focus on classic techniques but with a
modern kind of flourish we should like
to have a lot of fun with it we've kind
of taken all the [ __ ] can I say yeah
yeah you can all the [ __ ] out of
like the pretentious cocktail bar that
came up for the past you know five or
six seven years I think it's a
phenomenal branding we can give our
guests really really high-end expensive
spirits for a fourteen that's a win-win
for me except drunken socialism is
essentially illegal in Virginia thanks
to restrictive state liquor laws that
screw over bar owners and the average
drinking man yeah you can't give
something away well we're not really
giving it away because they're paying
cost for it but it's still implied as
you're giving it away and that's that's
the weird area that that we live in here
so John is forced to apply a small
markup on his break even bottle most
recent one is in the in the Box in the
middle up there is the John Fitzgerald
20 there there were 3,000 bottles
worldwide that were available the state
got something
100 I think wait what do you mean this
state got 100 we're at the mercy of what
if the state wants to bring it
you see Virginia is one of 17 alcoholic
beverage control states with a state
monopoly on wholesale or retail sales we
can try to push them along in the right
direction but we don't have we have no
set no well I've tried to bring Jen and
from California and it took three years
oh yeah that is [ __ ]
the lovely Prohibition era rules that we
have to kind of follow make things very
hard to be a bar in this state well if
the liquor can't be cheap
then maybe John can set up a free buffet
to lure new customers in actually that
won't work either 45 percent of our
gross sales has to be food if your ratio
is below 45 percent you can have a
written warning you can have your
license taken away you can be shut down
in most states when a bar gives away
liquor at cost it's much cheaper than
pouring a glass at home because bars buy
their bottles at wholesale prices not
true in Virginia the rogue gentleman
pays exactly the same price as anyone
walking into a liquor store and because
of the state-run monopoly those prices
are some of the highest in the country
we're paying retail price that's why our
prices are on we don't serve shitty
spirits here so where our cocktails are
12 13 14 bucks up to $18 and that's
awful you know you're making it harder
for me to make the stupid ratio you have
me make and if I don't I'm paralyzed
it's ridiculous and it's heartbreaking
and it's stressful to deal with this
nonsense people have been trying to get
the state out of the alcohol business
for decades but while some lawmakers
just want to control liquor consumption
many more are too afraid to give up the
lucrative revenue stream and I get that
it's a business you know I know the
Chairman and I bitched at him all the
time and
it's a business it's a business well I
got a [ __ ] business - when you're
killing me so about that Bernie Sanders
shirt well there's nothing that Bernie's
not gonna say disband ABC you know
that's not gonna happen
I like to service last cycle for many
reasons one being to ABC issue but until
we can get someone in in 20 years that
can privatize it somehow this is you
know your alcohol laws are terrible when
even Bernie Sanders supporting drunk and
socialists want to privatize the ABC